I would like to just begin by saying
I've had I am having a wonderful year
and I want to thank you and your
colleagues they know who they are for
your hospitality and your kindness to me
I think the life of the the writer is
largely being alone in a room and
somehow being over there and by early in
the place with lots of other people
alone in their rooms was is kind of
great and I had always thought one of
the reasons I was a writer was that I
didn't really like people and I come to
see that I actually like some people so
I just want to thank you very much so I
thought I would what I would do tonight
is is read a handful of older poems and
then read a couple brand-new poems
written over there and borrowed and then
read from my book which is just out I
just received a copy on Monday and I'd
like to acknowledge that by reading from
it
this poem is set up in the Adirondacks
where I like to go in the summer
whenever possible
it begins up there and then there's a
little flashback in the middle of it
and and then it returns concludes up
there
Twilight there's a black bear in the
apple tree and he won't come down I can
hear him panting like an athlete I can
smell the stink of his body come down
black bear can you hear me the mind is
the most interesting thing to me like
the sudden death of the Sun it seems
implausible the darkness will swallow it
or that anything is lost forever there
like a black bear in a fruit tree
gulping up sour apples with dry sucking
sounds or like us at the pier somber and
tired making food from sunlight you
saying a word me saying a word trying
hard though things were disintegrating
still I want to do your lips on my neck
your postmodern sexuality for Lauren and
anonymous I didn't want to be that I
could hear the great barking monsters of
the lower waters calling me forward you
see my mind takes me far but my heart
dreams of return black bear with pale
pink tongue at the center of his face is
turning his head like the face of Christ
from life shaking the Apple boughs he is
stronger than I am and seems so free of
passion no fear no pain
no tenderness I want to be that come
down black bear I want to learn the
faith of the indifferent
these next two poems are for my father
and my mother I always like to read
poems to them at the beginning of my
readings this poem is called oil and
steel just to frame it a little let me
say that my father grew up in North
Carolina and Sandhills there where his
parents were sharecroppers who grew
peaches and tobacco so he he oh he
finished her high school education oil
and steel my father lived in a dirty
dish mausoleum watching a portable
black-and-white television reading the
Encyclopedia Britannica which he
preferred to modern fiction one by one
his schnauzers died of liver disease
except the one that guarded his corpse
found holding a tumbler of Bushmills
dead is dead he would say an anti
preacher I took a plaid shirt from the
bedroom closet and some motor oil my
inheritance once I saw him weep in a
court room neglected needing nursing
this man who never showed me much
affection but gave me a knack for
solitude which has been mostly useful
my mother was born a French woman in
Marseilles and then when she was 20 she
came to the US and she spent Oh
fifty-five years trying to be an
American woman and then at the very end
of her life she completely reverted to
being a French woman again only speaking
French this poem is called sunflower
when mother and I first had that
do-not-resuscitate conversation she
lifted her head like a drooped sunflower
and said those dying
always want to stay months later on the
kitchen table Mars raid Mars red
gladiolas saying ode to joy' and we
listened house flies swooped and veered
around us like the Holy Spirit nature is
always expressing something human mother
commented her mouth twisting as I
plucked whiskers from around it yes no
please tenderness was not yet dust
mother sat up rubbed her eyes drowsily
her breaths like breakers the living man
the beach
this is another one set up there in the
Adirondacks and many of my poems
I think the mind engages with an animal
or a plant and then tries to extract
some knowledge from that experience and
then move forward toward some fresh idea
that's the idea here and in several of
these creaturely poems this is called
the hens where I took care of a flock of
hens up there one summer it's good for
the ego when I call and they come
running squawking and clucking because
it's feed time and once again I can't
resist picking up little Lazarus and
orange and white pull it
I adore yes yes everything will be okay
I say to her glaring mongrel face come
September she'll begin to lay the
blue-green eggs
I love poached God dooms the snake to
taste nothing
but the dust and the hen to 4,000 or so
ovulation 's poor Lazarus last spring
and intruder murdered her sisters and
left her garrotted in the coop there's a
way the wounded light up a dark
rectangular space suffering becomes the
universal theme to solved and you'll be
squeezed too hard and you'll be broken
even a hen knows this posing on a manure
pile her body a stab of gold
I think I'll read one more older poem
feels like thirty minutes have gone by
and just nine minutes have gone by
thinking what am I going to do let's see
so let's see this poem is called Beach
walk it conflates really two experiences
I had on the beach down in Florida where
my brother lives and and then and then
concludes with some some fresh idea as
the I was the strategy of the poem many
of these poems that I'm reading they do
employ strategies of the sonnet form
which is not to say that they're rhymed
or metered
but they have these kind of fractures
and leaps and resolutions in them that
are that are nonlinear and that are
enabled by that I think the sonnet form
Beachwalk I found a baby shark on the
beach
seagulls had eaten his eyes his throat
was bleeding lying on shell and sand
he looked smaller than he was the ocean
had scraped his insides clean when I
poked his stomach darkness rose up in
him like black water later I saw a boy
aroused and elated beckoning from a dune
like me he was alone
something tumbled between us not quite
emotion I could see the pink interior
flesh of his eyes I got lost where am I
he asked like a debt owed to death
I was pressing my face - its spear hefts
we fall we fell we are falling nothing
mitigates it the dark embryo bares its
teeth and we move on so I think I'll
read a couple newish poems never read
them so they might change well I know
they'll change this is called at the
grave of Robert Lowell one day last fall
on a beautiful bright fall day I drove
up to New Hampshire where Lowell was
buried in a family cemetery in the woods
and I wanted to write something about it
but he has so many he's on it's written
for others I thought I'd try and do the
same at the grave of Robert Lowell on
this tenth day of November I placed her
Vince key and sip vodka from a paper cup
taking in the view tendrils twining
leaves rippling guts absorbing nutrients
brains processing information all of it
is dust now he/she all of them lie under
sod men and women no longer rivals in
love bodies grow old and festered
history is like an impressionist
painting a variegated landscape of
emotional colors as night falls
owls bats and hedgehogs come out to hunt
I take joy in considering my generation
I rewrite to be read though I blush
acknowledging it scattered among
imposing trees the ancient
and the modern intersect spreading germs
of death and happiness I curl up in my
fleece and drink
let's see Joe here this next poem no Joe
is here this next poem was inspired by a
cult colleague of ours who has a little
film a scary film about a bird market
called Red Dawn so I wrote a poem called
Red Dawn which is a more personal poem
though the bird market inspired inspired
it mine is more like a chicken
processing Factory rather than a bird
market Red Dawn the transfer is done in
a dark room with a red light to keep
them calm
still it's stressful hanging upside down
when an electrical pulse shuts their
hearts down and the plucking rubber
fingers and mechanical rotary knife
begin the shackle line continually
moving like sterile meditations on a
life or the sacrifices one makes for an
enigmatic love as their legs and thighs
and wings are removed their heads are
pulled off in a channel their hearts and
livers preserved as edible offal even in
death will I want you still don't want
can have can't have want sometimes the
empty languor of the present is almost
unbearable worms crickets minnows after
the night how do they recover so fully
see I think I'll read from my book now
Helen the water yeah
so the poems in this new book are kind
of breaking away from the sonnet form
and they're kind of tercer more vertical
more taut you might say and I don't know
that there's any difference in content I
think there's a lighter a little area
this first poem is called free dirt I I
wrote it after coming upon a sign in you
know driving around coming up on a sign
people giving away some free dirt it
seemed to me like a marvelous trope for
for something there's a little French
line in it my French accent is so bad
but it's via to du ciel performed which
is from Baudelaire and beauty which is
do come from heaven you might say free
dirt my house is mine the choice of menu
the radio and television the unpolished
floors the rumpled sheets it's like
being inside a roll-top desk
I have no maid who takes care of me
sometimes during breakfast I speak
French with a taxidermied Rennes there
is no debt between us we listen to
language tapes the antutu CL performed
always I hear a little oratorio inside
my head moths have carried away my
carpets like invisible pallbearers I
live I like invisible nough succeptible
UN's strong broad raise some nights I
ask her paleness will I be okay I am
weak and fruitless at night like a piece
of meat with eyes but in the morning
optimistic again like a snowflake that
has travelled many miles and many years
to be admired on the kitchen pain alone
i guzzle and litter and urinate and
shout please do not wake me from this
dream making meals from discrete objects
a sweet potato a jar of marmalade a
bottle of Sauvignon Blanc
today I saw a sign in majuscule for free
dirt and thought we all have chapters
we'd rather keep unpublished in which we
get down with the swirl the little Wren
perched on my finger weighs almost
nothing just nails and beak but it gives
me tiny moments here at my kitchen table
like a diaphanous chorus mewling
something about love or the haze of love
a haze that makes me squint dyed and
sick if I think too much about it what
am I
but this flensed syntax sight and sound
in which my heart not insulated yet
makes ripple effects down the line
this is the poem I wrote after seeing a
show of textiles from Afghanistan Oh for
about 30 years
all those floral patterns we think of in
carpets have been replaced by grenades
and rife rifles missiles helicopters
fighter jets and that was really the the
seat for this poem called war rug the
pony and the deer are trapped by tanks
and the lady with the guitar is sad
beyond words hurtling across the sky a
missile has mistaken a vehicle for a
helicopter exploding in a ball of white
flame upside down Birds red specks of
knotted wool glow above the sideways
trees hidden among plants a barefooted
boy waits like the divine coroner aiming
an assault rifle at something enjoying
the attentions of a grey doggy or maybe
he is already dead
I have never you know I'm this book is
my ninth book and I don't think I've
ever dedicated poems to anyone at one so
I thought in this book I wanted to
dedicate a couple poems to people I
think they're four or five in the book
dedicated to folks I've known for a
while that have been kind to me over the
years and this one is to Jamaica Kincaid
she's here but Oh hate to make it I'm
glad you're here I'll never have this
opportunity again because the two people
I wanted to read these poems for are
actually in the audience so I'll feel I
can go home and die now die with
pleasure this one is called the bee and
I needn't say anything more
the bee for Jamaica Kincaid there's a
bee dying slowly outside my window
he/she makes this awful buzzing sound
which grows longer as the end nears I
suppose the mysterious process at work
within him/her is disturbing like a warm
wet finger usually when you hear a bee
the sound dissipates as the bee flies
away but this is constant so constant I
think maybe this bee is stupidly in love
with me
or the buzzing is inside my head and
will become over time a friend a new
kind that doesn't go away even after
lots of sex my ear canal growing
receptive like a hard bud to light or a
vulva to the perfect relation would we
know each other I wonder if our eyes met
across a crowded room I did not expect
to meet this bee what else could love be
but lots of buzzing or hate
go read three more the other night when
I went home I see three nights ago there
was a delivery from DHL and I opened it
up I thought what is this it was from
England and I opened it up and there was
a can of sardines in the box no
indication it was a gift from someone
but it was just a can of English
sardines and in virgin olive oil and
this poem is called sardines so it must
have some relation to that gift but it
hasn't revealed itself the source yet I
think it's a joke a kind of practical
joke of some kind sardines cutting a
slit from the throat to vent and pulling
out the innards rinsing and stuffing the
insides with lemon and thyme wrapping
the flesh and paper-thin prosciutto to
keep to keep it from falling apart then
creating a little oil slick to fire them
up like naked figures harbored in my bed
I think I must draw a veil over the past
I must feel nothing in connection with
it but then standing there eating for
fools like white violets pondering a sky
dark with storm and rain I also think if
I were a little sparrow I'd fly straight
to him
just to left and I'm finally relaxed so
sphere this is another poem for my
father
really spear sir I don't have no black
tea
the waitress replied so I ordered Black
Label instead it was summer and the
fragrant white flowers of the black
locust had awakened like fairies or
obscure matter
a black bear clothed and thorns made a
mess of the bird feeder were hungry
Black Caps were a vision and the black
flies were biting energetically Billy
died of the black death I shouldn't call
it that and hovered like a wing at
horsemen there's nothing so wrong as
when young folks died I smashed my bike
blacked out and got two black eyes at
the Mayo Clinic
daddy had his arteries cleared praising
the surgeons fine black hands after he
died we called everyone in his black
book and found a black space that
couldn't be lifted by impotent wings
like me he was the black sheep there
were struggles once driving near Black
Mountain he blurted there ain't nothing
so good a stolen corn or watermelon his
face was like a smiling black spiders
questioning the earth from which he came
son you got mixed blood and that drew
him back he cleared a way forward into
the murky light beside the roadside
blacktop a deer with black diamonds and
in its eyes lay in a bed of black pans
these around us black ash and black
walnuts made of velvety curtin dead ten
years he visits me often like a head
behind bars with that black temper and
black bile still coming out of his mouth
but tenderness to like black gold did I
love him back
I wonder if I loved him with all my
heart and all my liver why did I spit
him in the river
this last poem I'm going to read is
dedicated to hell and endler it's the
last poem in my book when I first was
hired here as a Briggs Copeland 21 years
ago Helen was on the committee that
hired me
the constant leaf I wish my father was
here his features were calm and striking
even when his breasts were horrible
remote pale yellow sunlight behind a
screen of clouds landscape in darkness
rain comes straight down in dense
strands to cover the street with rain
froth the trees are so full it makes
everything seem constant but fragile as
if any moment could be the last all the
news is the same news
somebody bombing somebody somebody
cheating somebody somebody hurting the
one he loves so we talk about
forgiveness in a low-key unabashed way
forgive me for the errors of my youth
forgive me for the fatal incurable virus
that caused your blindness forgive me
for the stinger that blew up your
tenement the wind tears a powerline from
the pole sparking a transfer sparking a
transformer and the brick pavement is
saturated like mud when I closed my eyes
and hold my breath I can stay in one
place detoxifying experience like a
kidney it's strange how the past holds
on to us how the rapture of the lonely
shore is agreeable only if we can at any
moment to scape it and how the night
feel so indispensable soothing on the
television at the white domed capital a
white man in a white room lifts his
glass of white wine I'm always searching
the faces of strangers for a friend
thank you very much
you